[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is of course a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
okay
right
it's impossible we don't make mistakes
yeah so far literally hundreds and
hundreds of challengers not one winner
no one's been able to catch us i know
i'm i'm actually a little surprised too
i i would have thought we would have
made a mistake by now but we haven't i
think that sentence was mumbled and done
listen
i think we got our first one right here
so tired
what's drinky winky you having hawaii no
i'm fine okay uh well tonight a fan
named shannon thinks she caught a
mistake she says it happened when i was
talking recently with simon hellberg of
the big bang theory here's shannon
hey conan in the episode where you were
interviewing simon helberg you told him
that his show was a juggernaut
except you didn't say juggernaut you
said juggernaut
twice
so i just want to let you know that
that's not how you pronounce it it's
juggernaut anyway don't hate me sorry
wow okay well shannon i'd love to take
your word for it but you're clearly a
very disturbed person
look check out what you have in the
background next to your computer
a bottle of antidepressants
and the dolls you stole off of someone
else's wedding cake
you're clearly insane
she made that look at that look at that
look at she's
your mood changes
your mood changes are mad but still i i
think we do need to address what she
brought up sure crazy or not
shannon i'm sorry you're dead wrong the
word is pronounced juggernaut okay and
who should know better than someone with
the same name that's right i'm talking
about marvel comics bad guy
juggernaut
or as shannon calls him
juggernaut
well anyway
check out this scene from the director's
cut of x-men 3 the last stand where
juggernaut as she calls him squares off
against wolverine on alcatraz island
you always make such a mess out of my
way wolverine unless you're prepared to
die sorry juggernaut the only thing i'm
saying you're not
what it's pronounced juggernaut like the
word juggernaut
but the word is juggernaut
actually the origin of the word is
hebrew it refers to the unstoppable
force that is the jewish people of which
i am one
you're jewish prove it
say something in hebrew fine
israel
baruch s
are you saying we forget this whole
mutant war thing and go for a schwitz
does a rabbi eat mata on pesach
let's go sweat
[Applause]
well i think that proves we're right it
sure does a real x-men movie clip
with a klezmer ending shut up
so the challenge still stands ladies and
gentlemen if you think you've spotted an
era on our show report it at
teamcoco.com
ha ha i found an error we will sort it
out right here on the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make jump
meat out of the maestro we'll take a
little